doing any sort of digging without
knowing what's beneath can really be
dangerous which is why you should always
call eight one one before digging today
as it turns out is national call 811
before you dig day steve miller with
southwest gas an old colleague of mine
as a matter of fact joins us to talk
more about this important issue why is
it so important when we talk about
dangers what could happen if you dig
without calling absolutely so if you
were to dig in your yard whether you're
planting a tree a shrub a mailbox or
doing some larger excavation work if you
were to do that before or without
calling 8-1-1 you could damage an
electrical line which could lead to
electrocution you could hit a natural
gas line you could hit a sewer line so
what you do is you call 8-1-1 two days
before you plan on your beginning
beginning your project we'll come out
we'll mark the lines and that way you'll
know where you can dig safely yeah so
you do need to give a 48-hour window so
there is enough time for someone to come
out and check things out absolutely and
it's two two business days so um if
you're planning on digging on saturday
you know give them a call on tuesday and
we'll come out like i said before you
begin your project you'll see the color
lines um so you know where we're not
we're not to dig yeah you know you see
those colors all the time they represent
something it's national uh wherever you
go the same colors mean the same thing
absolutely it's a national color code so
red is electric uh yellow natural gas
blue is your water line green is your
sewer line and the orange are
telecommunications lines so you want to
avoid all of those because if you hit
one you could knock out service to to
your neighborhood right you could get
injured or even worse be unpopular with
your neighbors for sure
are you responsible for damages like
that if you do not call 811 ahead of
time absolutely in addition to possibly
being injured uh you will be responsible
for paying for the damages to the to the
line that you cause how long has 8-1-1
been around uh that's a good question
yeah
but it's this is obviously a national
call 8-1-1 before you dig day so it's it
is something that's across the nation
absolutely uh every every city has their
own version of 8-1-1 but 8-1-1 is a
national program um and even though
today is august 11th this is something
that should be practiced year-round yeah
no doubt all right great information
steve good to see you as always uh give
southwest gas a call if you have any
questions we want to thank southwest gas
for sponsoring this segment you can call
that phone number there
go to 877-860-6020